irène joliot propose voyage sans
passeport compagnie d'irène catarivas ce
venkat arribas ses lumières annonce la
vie nocturne de jérusalem en fait de vie
nocturne vous savez jérusalem n'est pas
tellement gâtés noué en ce qui concerne
l'appellation vie nocturne
jérusalem est une ville très sérieuse
c'est la capitale de l'état d'israël
c'est la ville sainte par excellence et
oui mais je m'excuse mais toute vie
nocturne comporte aussi pas mal de
travaux d'eau particulièrement celui des
journaux de la presse diana dans les
services 8 ceux qui travaillent la nuit
nous sont démontrés ici et non seulement
vous avez un journal qui s'imprime à
jérusalem les détails journaux puisque
pays d'immigration pays où les gens sont
arrivés d'horizons très divers il soit
ils ne connaissent pas tous la langue
alors qu'on a vu on imprime différents
journaux dans différentes langues c'est
ça en effet il ya des quotidiens 20 des
langues aussi diverses que le turc
l'anglais oui l'ancien journal
s'appelait par l'espagne post
aujourd'hui il s'appelle le jaws l'impôt
c'est un quotidien de langue anglaise
de même de même qu'il ya quotidien de
langue française est également des
hebdomadaires jérusalem ville sept
villes dans lesquelles les petits vieux
de plus de prières foisonnent les gens
vont prier pour la prière du soir ce ne
sont pas de grandes synagogues
ce ne sont pas des cathédrales ce sont
des lieux où on enseigne et on apprend
jérusalem sous son aspect qui se
modernise du reste chaque jour il est
toujours impossible de dire la jérusalem
d'aujourd'hui parce que je crois que
c'est déjà celle d'hier mais ceux ci
c'est le quartier de méa shéarim et vous
me disiez si justement l'autre jour dans
lorsque nous bavardions vous me disiez
irène chagnaud il est impossible de
comprendre israël
si l'on ne comprend pas méa shéarim et
si on ne le voit pas bien entendu il y a
eu toujours des juifs qui voulaient
revenir en terre sainte pour y mourir
pour eux c'était très important de
retrouver le sol de la terre sainte
ils sont donc arrivés au début du siècle
et même avant il habitait la jérusalem
anciennes et ce n'est que beaucoup plus
tard qu'ils ont débordé les murs de la
vieille ville et qu'ils ont commencé à
vivre dans les quartiers modernes et lui
oui mais ce sont aujourd'hui les
quartiers les plus anciens
c'était en particulier méa shéarim
c'était le quartier de montefiore
s'étaient toutes sortes de quartier pour
lesquelles ces gens là devait enfin il
devait avoir un courage fou pour aller
en dehors dehors des murs de la ville
ancienne
oui nous sommes en ce moment dans une
famille normale ans oui enfin je sens
venir il a cité plutôt annie la famille
moyenne qui se prépare le matin on se
prépare très tôt en israël par tous
la journée commence de très bonne heure
puisque dans les ministères même on
commence au point si j'ose dire à 19h45
et on se tait on termine on termine la
journée continue
en été elle seule elle se termine vers
deux heures à cause de la chaleur en
hiver c'est plus tard trois heures avec
une petite interruption ou régionaux et
oui guère plus qu elle 108 vous savez
qu'en israël on mange le repas principal
soit non je dirais le matin oui cette
date il est jeune et du matin dit j'en
mange repas comparables et cet enjeu
dans le récit de ses leçons il ya de
nombreuses écoles je suppose aussi mais
le l'enseignement chez vous doit poser
un problème parce que c'est pas pour le
sabre à qui est née sur place et qui que
les bouées mais pour les autres enfants
c'est tout de même beaucoup plus
compliqué ce qui arrive de tous les
coins du monde et qui a un beau matin se
trouve à prendre l'histoire leur propre
pays en hébreu il faudra pas en avant
l'hébreu ou bien est ce que on en scène
et bienne en commun on commence
directement avec ces enfants-là de leur
enseigner tout leur patrimoine dans la
langue de la bible c'est évidemment très
difficile on a trouvé des méthodes
spéciales pour cela lorsque ça se passe
dans un village d'études de nouveaux
immigrants ça n'est pas difficile
puisqu'ils sont tous deux du maître du
même pays
mais lorsqu'il arrive dans une ville
jérusalem comme nous avons devant nous
il ya des écoles spéciales d'accueil des
classes spéciales d'accueil aux nouveaux
immigrants oui jerusalem éclate de tous
les côtés et ils ont construit
maintenant en dehors même des propres
rangs pas je crois qu autrefois là on
est au centre de jérusalem nous sommes
devant les bâtiments de l'agencé juive
c'est à dire les centres du nouveau
quartier d'habitations de jérusalem et
nous sommes maintenant nous voyons
arriver les étudiants ou hiver d'un
aveugle avec son chien s'est passé oui
c'est de cette façon la liane aide
edwy aide à son ami et bien nous
arrivons à terra santa qui est le
bâtiment central de l'ancienne
université vous savez que quand l'état
d'israël s'est créé jérusalem a été
coupée en deux d'un côté la ville
ancienne
de l'autre côté la ville nouvelle il se
trouve que université hébraïque
fondée en 1925 était sur le mont scopus
c'est à dire entre les deux zones en
territoire démilitarisé alors ça crée
une situation extrêmement difficile
aussi bien pour les étudiants que pour
les professeurs il fallait se contenter
de bâtiments provisoires et yam avec 55
ce n'est que beaucoup plus tard qu on a
reconstruit une nouvelle université
hébraïque et en ce moment nous voyons
comment ça se passait à ce moment-là
dans les 55 bâtiments provisoires et
tout était même traduit en braille pour
ce pauvre garçon oui nous avons une
expérience
malheureusement assez grande dans ses
problèmes d'éducation aux aveugles
ce qui permet ce qui nous permet même
d'exporter si j'ose dire des
spécialistes dans les nouveaux pays
d'afrique où également la cécité et très
grand v ya beaucoup de jeunes aveugles
voilà le train je ne pense pas qu'il y
en ait beaucoup
en israël non il ya eu il ya une ligne
qui monte sur jérusalem il ya une ligne
qui descend vers le sud
et finalement il faut bien dire les
choses en israël on n'est pas tellement
habitués à voyager par le train le
réseau routier beaucoup plus important
lorsque quelqu'un désire se déplacer il
le fait en autobus
armand mais les marchandises bien sûr
oui bien sûr on lit ce qu'on les
transporte tout de même par par le rail
je dois dire que le matériel de chemin
de fer israël est en grande partie du
matériel venant de france avant les gens
très fier il ya eu un emprunt il fait
savez vous avec le matériel français
excellent merci
voilà toute la vie continue celle ci se
doit être celle du boulanger oui la vie
nocturne je crois de nouveau ça c'est
pas possible autrement le pain se fait
aussi la nuit en israël non eh bien oui
le pain se fait la nuit et le pain se
fait dans des usines
il n'y a pas de boulangerie a bien
quelque chose de très curieux pour
quelqu'un qui arrive pour la première
fois en israël qui a envie d'acheter un
morceau de pain ils cherchent la
boulange est au coin de la rue ça
n'existe pas nous sommes je crois déjà
dans la sismique dans l'institut
l'industrie pharmaceutique qui est
extrêmement florissant pluie et beaucoup
de choses oui et nous exportons
également des produits pharmaceutiques
je crois que le légume israélien existe
vraiment maintenant sur le marché
vous avez vraiment réussi à le faire
sortir de terre il n'est pas ça été très
dur parce que dans un pays où la
pierraille domine la terre ça se lit la
marche et à jérusalem
oui évidemment c'était difficile elle
est d'abord enlever la pierre et ensuite
faire pousser des légumes et c'était du
fromage
il vient et beaucoup de spécialités de
fromages chez vous nous commençons tout
juste dans ce domaine nous sommes
certainement bien plus à notre rêve dans
la librairie encore que nous fabriquions
en israël un fromage à l'as roquefort
qui est tout au plus un bon bleu
d'auvergne et autres fromages d'autres
fromages qui portent de très jolis noms
hommage dans la rue si je suis bon et
beau pays d'orient énormément lise rien
pouvoir son jus de fruits mange son
phallus en lettres carottes sont juste
inventé games étant alors en israël que
j'ai appris et cra à faire du jus de
carotte il paraît que c'est excellent
pour les bébés a dû plus un bébé
pourtant j'ai trouvé ça très beau et on
y mange les falafels qui sont le lemay
nationale si j'ose dire ce sont des
boulettes de farine de pois chiche on
met dans des princes arabes en forme de
boulettes et ça se mange beaucoup dans
la rue alors cette dame s'en va dans ce
qui est aujourd'hui devenue l'une des
grandes boutiques de
de musique d'israël mais qui à l'époque
au moment où il n'y avait pas encore
d'académie de musique servait d'académie
de musique c'est l'académie roupies en
pardon robin et oui l'accabler me
comprend toutes sortes de possibilités
dans le domaine artistique et
spécialement musical et chorégraphique
et nous avons retrouvé notre ami
leveugle son ami le chien
sa solde qui parents adoptifs et adnane
khamis au départ c'est une chose
merveilleuse de voir que ce garçon qui
est sans doute un blessé de guerre oui à
retrouver une activité est un moyen de
gagner sa vie
on a fait énormément d'efforts nous
avons beaucoup de téléphonistes aveugle
nous avons à succès qui n'est dû se
passer au moment des ruines n'est ce pas
ce que l'on montre aujourd'hui aux
téléspectateurs c'est dans cet état là
qu'on a retrouvé les maisons et
jérusalem a été très d'être être très
enfin vraiment ya des combats horribles
au moment de la guerre d'indépendance et
tout ce que vous avez vu tout à l'heure
c'était la jérusalem redite moderne
encore qu'elle soit bien plus moderne
que ça aujourd'hui mais à cinq minutes
près on ne peut pas dire que l'on
connaît géruzet ne sachant trop tôt oui
des cahiers d'enfants
toute la vie par terre la guerre dans
tous les pays laisse toujours des traces
oui c'est ce que je vais dire
malheureusement nous sommes familiarisés
triste spectacle qui vous souhaitez
comme les reverra jamais c'est nous
sommes très près précisément à jérusalem
cette ville qui est coupée en deux par
ce mur enfin qui est presque un mur de
la honte comme comme ailleurs nous
sommes toujours très près de la guerre
et il n'est pas rare qu'il y ait des
balles qui fusent encore récemment il ya
eu des balles qui sont perdus je peux
vous en parler en connaissance de cause
ceux reçus il ya eu des impacts de balle
au dessus du lit d'un bébé de dans la
maison d'un ami à moi ils arrivent
constamment mais la vie continue
on construit et on construit beaucoup
oui ça et je génération pousse c'est un
excellent moyen ça pour nous mais je n'y
avais jamais pensé mais ça me paraissait
formidable de signer je ne sais pas
faire les uns ford est comme cela que ça
n'a pas l'air de là ça les amuse sait
pas qui est le cheval pour leur esprit
qui sait où vient le moment mais
nouveaux immigrants qui arrivent de tous
les pays du monde et qui continue à
s'installer et la flamme de vie chère au
coeur israélien il s'agit d'une flamme
assez spécial il s'agit de la flamme de
la fête des lumières qui est un
raccourci la victoire des faibles sur
les plus forts et au moment de la fête
des lumières c'est à dire de hanouka il
y à des défilés de jeunes dans toutes
les rues du pays
nous sommes en ce moment à jérusalem
tous les mouvements de jeunesse ont leur
défilé aux flambeaux sont très très
heureux et très fier de participer au
spectacle et la cérémonie à la fois
irene kahn arrive à ce je vous remercie
une fois de nous avoir permis de mieux
connaître votre pays
irène chagnaud vous a proposé voyage
sans passeport en compagnie d'ivan
catarivas ce montage vo script simone
chez vos draps sont jean claude brisseau
illustration sonore dominique valadié de
réalisation solange pétait
e